oh mets dans le panier mets dans le
panier met dans le
paniercore est on va
chercher c'est qu'il y en
[Musique]
a
allez on continue encore
[Musique]
encore baiss ça y
est regarde
partout qu'
[Musique]
manque
tellement Alexa c'était une jeune fille
pleine de
vie une jeune fille qui qui représentait
la joie de vivre qui était notre
[Musique]
bonheur oui on va aller ouvrir les
cadeauz à toi tout
[Musique]
ça
tout ça c'est pour
toi Jonathan ce petit garçon gentil
c'est l'allure qui se donne mais il en
joue de ça il en joue de
[Musique]
ça il était capable de tout il était
capable de tout de tuer de brûler de
mentir d'accuser les
autres
et le fait qu'il décide de mettre sa
femme à mort qu'on met comme on met un
mise à mort d'un
animal je ne peux pas l'intégrer je ne
peux pas le supporter je ne veux pas que
ça arrive à d'autres jeunes filles je il
faut que ça s'arrête ces
[Musique]
féminicides
Alexia en 2017 c'était la
147e c'est un numéro et derrière ce
numéro et un visage et une
famille6e c'était qui la 148e c'était
qui
[Musique]
Alexia je voudrais qu'on qu'on ne
l'oublie pas et je voudrais aussi qu'on
n'oublie pas toutes ces victimes ces
jeunes filles on a aucun nom on les
connaît pas alors que elles ont eu une
[Musique]
[Rires]
vievo et moi j'ai besoin de parler
Alexia pour pas
que pour la faire exister à la
porte qu'elle ne soit pas morte pour
rien c'est qu'il
[Musique]
est
m c'est
[Musique]
alia
gré c'est c'est une petite ville où où
tout le monde connaît connaît tout le
monde il y a une impression de calme de
de douceur c'est une ville confortable O
où il fait bon
vivre quand on traverse gré on traverse
une une petite ville qui a ses
industries certaines qui sont encore en
fonction d'autres qui ont
malheureusement quitter la ville on on
traverse un pont très joli et puis tout
de suite après le pont il y a il y a le
bar de nos parents on y a passé
tellement de de temps on y a grandi on y
a
évolué je suis Stéphanie Guay j'ai 39
ans et je suis la sœur
d'Alexia le bar pour moi c'est une
histoire de famille bien sûr tout le
monde a été impliqué dans dans le bar
surtout au début Alexia venait nous
aider quand elle pouvait le weekend
Stéphanie SIS arrivit de Paris il savait
que notre vie était
là c'était le projet d'une
[Musique]
famille j'ai quitté l'école à 17 ans je
suis rentré dans une
entreprise où je suis resté 31 ans en
tant que tourneur fraiser et j'avais
toujours eu envie d'ouvrir un commerce
Isabelle aussi je me suis dit bon ben
puisqu'ils m'ont licencié le bar PMU
était à vendre lieu où nous allions
fréquemment boire le café et ben on a
craqué mon épouse après 25 ans de chef
caissière à casino m'a suivi et nous
avonsmené notre petite barque pendant 15
ans dans ce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bar R des agré pour passer quelques
jours de vacances en famille et puis en
même temps on allait fêter
l'anniversaire de notre fils au sein de
la famille on venait retrouver voilà
Alexia et et Jonathan chez mes
beaux-parents je m'appelle Grégory Guay
je suis le mari de Stéphanie qui est la
sœur
[Musique]
d'Alexia on prépare déjà ses vacances
avec ma sœur depuis quelques temps on
s'échange des messages comme on a la
habitude de le faire des textos quasi
quotidiens pour se raconter nos journées
et puis prévoir ces vacances
[Musique]
là c'est les vacances scolaires de la
tousin j'attendais ce moment avec
impatience parce que je savais que on
allait souffler les bougies de James
tous ensemble on avait préparé des
[Musique]
cadeaux tu vasir nous faire des
hamburger la pâte àie tu vas nous faire
des
hamburger et le gros
cadeauoui par
ou James nous c'est notre premier petit
enfant on est très fier d'avoir ce ce
beau petit garçon Alexia elle est super
fière d'être sa tata chérie et pour elle
James ça représente un bonheur infini et
je pense que elle doit se projeter dans
les yeux de James c'est quoi
ça je pense qu'elle doit se projeter en
se
disant
un jour j'aurai aussi mon propre
enfant la fin de l'été a
été difficile compliqué pour ma sœur
puisquelle a fait face à une fausse
couche
CELI elle a éé abatue dans le sens où
elle a été très malheureuse de cette de
cette fausse couche ça a été assez dur à
encaisser elle a eu plus de à s'en
remettre que elle ne l'avait imaginé
après on était également au courant mais
il y a très peu de personnes dans la
famille qui le savaient ma femme et moi
on étions au courant que Alexia avait
des des blackout et qu'elle consultait
pour ça et que ça l'inquiétait un peu
pour elle ces malais c'était des des
blackout c'est elle qui les a qualifié
comme ça elle me disait qu'elle avait
des des
moments dont elle ne se rappelait pas
mais que c'était des moments qui
semblaient euh quand même duré et euh ça
ne lui arrivait que chez
[Musique]
elle ma sœur ce soir-là je sais juste
qu'elle est agacée parce que son mari
n'est toujours pas là et euh et et c'est
[Musique]
tout
elle lui fera remarquer quand il
arrivera que on l'attendait plus tôt et
qu'il avait dit qu'il arriverait plus
tôt c'est une petite réflexion sans
animosité particulière il y a vraiment
rien d'extraordinaire c'est une soirée
tout à fait
banale
[Applaudissements]
apaisé va jouer ici il y a rien qui
laisse présager quoi que ce soit il y a
pas
de je ne sens aucune tension je ne
ressens aucun mal-être je ne moi je ne
vois que le bonheur d'être
ensemble je ne vois que ça
[Musique]
moi je l'embrasse je lui voir et on se
donne rendez-vous le
lendemain
voilà c'est le dernier souvenir que j'ai
d'Alexia je la vois dans sa petite veste
rose qui s'en
va je la prends dans les bras et on se
dit à
[Musique]
demain
le lendemain matin je me réveille je
suis en
retard au lieu de me réveiller à 5h
comme je fais tous les jours je me
réveille à 6h25 6h30 donc là c'est la
catastrophe je me
dépêche
[Applaudissements]
et là je me suis mis en route un petit
peu en catastrophe mais ça y est la
machine était partie mais je suis arrivé
en
retard
le samedi matin il était prévu que je
reste à la maison d'habitude je vais
travailler mais
là je suis contente on fait le petit
déjeuner avec James tranquillement avec
Stéphanie
greégory sachant que le midi on devait
se retrouver à manger tous au bar avec
Alexia et pour pouvoir ensuite aller
bagnoder toutes
les filles ensemble quoi on s'occupe du
petit on prend notre déjeuner tous
ensemble tout tout va tout va très bien
et puis quelques temps après je prends
mon téléphone et je découvre un un
message venant du téléphone de ma sœur
qui me dit que elle est partie courir et
que éventuellement elle passerait nous
voir à la maison dans sa course ce qui
est éit dans ce message c'est qu'elle
court à
l'extérieur en pleine rue ça ça me
paraît bizarre surtout que il fait il
fait beau mais il fait très
froid ça me paraît bizarre parce qu'elle
a jamais fait ça elle court plutôt chez
elle sur son tapis de cour et passe
rarement nous voir lors d'une course
[Musique]
extérieure
moi j'étais au
bar avec la clientèle sympa du matin
et Jonathan arrive sur le coup des
10h il passe derrière le bar m'embrasser
on se dit bonjour ça va oui ça
va et Jonathan me
dit je suis inquiet alexia est partie
courir elle était pas en fort me je
voulais pas qu'elle y all mais ça m'a
pas interpellé plus que ça mais lui il
m'a il m'a montré que il était contrarié
il est passé vite il a il s'est fait
lui-même son petit café on a bu le café
ensemble et puis il est reparti aussi
vite il m'a dit qu'il allait déposer un
ordi ou faire quelque chose sur son lieu
de travail et puis c'est
tout
tout d'un coup ça sonne à la
porte on voit Jonathan qui arrive
décomposé en nous disant qu'Alexia était
parti
courir et que ça faisait 1 heure 1 heure
1 heure qu elle était toujours pas
[Musique]
rentrée tout ça va très vite il arrive
dans un état second tout ce que je vois
c'est qu'il est affolé Alexia n'est pas
rentré j'ai peur il s'est passé quelque
chose quand il arrive nous on est
complètement déboussolé on comprend pas
du tout pourquoi il est dans cet état là
et au moment où il nous dit ça je pense
que nos premières pensées notre première
réflexe c'est de se dire elle a trouvé
quelqu'un qu'elle connaît sur la route
elle s'est arrêté boire un café quelque
part avec une copine et elle va
arriver
[Musique]
et lui il nous dit si si je suis
persuadé qu'il y a quelque chose de pas
normal je me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'il
nous
fait donc là moi je me pose pas plus de
questions que ça juste passer à l'action
en disant ben maintenant Jonathan tu
viens avec moi on va prendre ma voiture
et on va aller la
chercher et Jonathan est ébé dans dans
ma voiture je vois il est il a l'air
d'être un peu décontenancé
puis le regard un peu bas donc puis moi
je suis là en train de lui dire écoute
tiens regarde dans le faosset si tu vois
quelque chose des indices voilà il faut
faut trouver
Alexia et après il va m'emmener chez lui
je me gare et on rentre par le sous-sol
et j'aurais pas j'ai pas d'explication
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
je je me dis tiens je je reste je reste
en bas je ressens juste que je je vais
m'arrêter là je me mets un frein pour ne
pas le suivre dans la
maison et donc je l'entends monter dans
la maison et appeler Alexia Alexia pas
de trace d'Alexia non plus là-bas j'ai
des nouvelles de mon mari au moment où
il décide d'aller aux urgences
puis il décide aussi d'aller au
commissariat de
gendarmerie et là quand il parle de
gendarmerie je
commence à réaliser qu'Alexia n'est
toujours pas là et que c'est peut-être
pas
normal alors notre arrivé à la
gendarmerie je crois même que je dis à
Jonathan écoute on peut-être pas en
attendre grandchose parce que il est
encore un peu tôt c'est une grande fille
Alexia je Seris étonné qu' s'en occupe
avant 24 48 Twitter et je suis très
agréablement surpris parce que on est
pris au sérieux tout de suite la
gendarme qui qui nous accueille dit ben
je préviens le
procureur c'est un samedi je suis en
famille juste avant midi et donc les
enquêteurs de la jourerie Gray
m'appellent pour m'indiquer qu'un homme
s présenter signalant la la disparition
de sa femme alors c'est des personnes
qui sont jeunes qui ont moins de 30 ans
la disparition la cohision d'un footing
bon c'est quelque chose qui quand même
assez rare qui attire mon
attention et donc bien entendu comme
c'est très bien faire la gendarmerie
c'est immédiatement la mise en place
d'un dispositif de recherche très
important sur l'endroit précis où elle
était susceptible de faire son
footing
[Musique]
je m'appelle Yv ragin je suis retraité
de la gendarmerie depuis le mois d'août
2022 moi j'étais directeur opérationnel
de l'enquête le premier objectif c'est
de mettre en place tous les moyens
disponibles pour retrouver la personne
qui a disparu
engager les différentes unités
territoriales également pleton de
surveillance et d'intervention les
équipes cophiles et puis les
hélicoptères voire les plongeurs si
besoin on arrive à l'accueil où Jonathan
explique que qu'Alexia n'est pas revenu
d'un jogging et du coup je participe à
la première audition avec
lui
[Musique]
Jonathan n'explique pas grand chose à
mon sens au gendarmes tout comme quand
il était dans la voiture avec moi je le
trouve assez évasif assez
passif et je j'interpelle Jonathan en
lui disant écoute tu as rien de plus à
leur dire là je sais pas tuas pas tu
m'avais parlé d'un voisin qui avait
harcelé Alexia à une époque tu dis mais
dis-le c'est une piste c'est la première
piste vers laquelle il faut
s'orienter il en parle mais parce que je
lui ai dit de le faire et c'est ça qui
qui est dingue en fait c'est que
spontanément on dirait que Jonathan il
attend que les Ch chose se passe et
sinon il disait
[Musique]
rien ouverture d'une information
judiciaire pour enlèvement et
séquestration dans l'affaire de la
disparition d'Alexia Daval un appel à
témoins a été lancé Dimitri Ramelot vous
vous êtes rendu dans la famille d'Alexia
Daval ce matin une famille détruite par
l'inquiétude on imagine le pire qu'on la
retrouve pas que soit nappée morte
quelque part qu'elle crie au secours et
puis qu'on l'entende
[Musique]
pas ah benah là moi je commence à à
paniquer je suis allé partout le long de
la SA dans mais surtout moi j'étais axé
dans les bois de de gré et là j'ai fait
toutes les través de bois en hurlant
Alexia Alexia j'ai jamais crié aussi
fort j'avais la gorge
sèche j'ai rencontré des gens dans les
allées de boil je leur ai demandé voir
s'ils avaient pas vu une jeune
jogueuse croisé sur leur chemin mais non
personne n'avait rien
[Musique]
vu là on sait que les gendarmes vont
arriver et c'est là qu'on prend
l'ampleur de la chose les hélicoptères
qui commencent à
[Musique]
tourner commence à se croire dans une
série télé et c'est à ce moment-là qu'on
prend la mesure de ce qui est en train
de de
[Musique]
commencer
on prévient toute la famille là on
prévient tout le
monde pour et tout le monde vient à son
j devant la maison pour attendre les
gendarmes ce samedi après-midi là je
suis à la maison je regarde un match de
foot et à la mi-temps du match de foot
machinalement je prends mon téléphone
et là j'aperçois sur mon compte facebook
un avis de recherche lancé par Stéphanie
la sœur
d'Alexia je ressens un peu de panique je
me dis c'est pas possible ça peut pas
nous arriver ça peut pas nous arriver
donc sur
ce je prends ma voiture et quand
j'arrive devant la maison il y a déjà
Jean-Pierre avec quelques clients du bar
qui viennent au
nouvelles
moi Jean-Pierre c'est mon frère j'ai
jamais vu pleurer en fait c'est c'est un
gars solide et là je quand je le vois
avec les yeux rougis je me dis là il se
passe vraiment quelque chose quoi il y a
il y a quelque chose qui va
pas tout le monde est réuni sur le
trottoir puisqu'on entre pas dans le
domicile il y a Jonathan qui est
complètement effondré euh recroquevillé
sur lui-même dans une couverture euh
entouré par sa mère qui elle est en
pyjama euh je trouve ça très étrange un
adulte en pyjama au milieu de la rue à
midi
passé je lui pose la question je lui je
lu demande pourquoi elle est elle est en
pyjama elle me dit qu'il l'avait appelé
en urgence en catastrophe et que du coup
elle était venue comme elle était mais
pour moi elle a passé la nuit
ici quand j'arrive au domicile je vois
déjà énormément de de voitures
énormément de de monde sur
place je m'appelle thbao fouillot et je
suis le cousin
d'Alexia
[Musique]
j'avais 28 ans au moment des faits le
même âge
qu'Alexia on est plus de 30 on est même
une quarantaine à la maison à être
abassourdi par ce qui arrive à pas
savoir forcément comment comment réagir
à attendre les instructions et surtout à
à prendre soin de Jonathan en
fait
en sortant de mon travail je vais
directement chez chez Alexia puisque je
sais que tout le monde est
[Musique]
là directement je vais voir Stéphanie je
dis mais qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
qu'ils sont disputés hier soir quand
quand vous mangez ensemble elle me dit
non non non tout s'est bien passé ils
sont pas disputés non puis je vais voir
Jonathan et je lu dis mais Jonathan
j'espère que tu as un bon alibi parce
que tu sais quand une femme disparaît
c'est le mari qui a accusé en premier et
là tout de suite il m'a dit euh oui oui
j'ai un bon alibi j'étais parti emmener
du compost chez mes parents et j'ai vu
le maire du village qui était là aussi
donc oui moi j'ai j'ai un bon
alibi moi je suis Lydia fouillot la
tante d'Alexia la sœur de son papa pour
moi je suis soulagée parce que c'est pas
lui puis je je suis à milieu de penser
que c'est lui en plus parce que ça peut
pas arriver chez nous ça arrive que chez
les autres et donc voilà on pense pas
que ce genre de de de crime puisse
arriver dans nos
[Musique]
maisons Jonathan on le percevait comme
une petite personne
fragile
c'est ce que j'ai souvent dit aux
enquêteurs Jonathan je veux bien
l'envisager comme un suspect mais ça
s'écroule tout de suite parce qu'il est
pas capable je pensais sincèrement qu'il
était pas capable ni ni d'avoir force
physique ni d'avoir la force mentale de
faire ça de tuer quelqu'un de le cacher
de mentir à tout le
monde moi je pensais qu'Alexia avait été
[Musique]
kidnappé
je me disais bon c'est pas c'est pas
possible que ça soit Jonathan qui a fait
quelque chose à Alexia c'est le couple
le couple parfait ils viennent de se
marier il y a un an qu'ils sont mariés
ils viennent d'habiter dans la
[Musique]
maison tout va bien pour eux ils ont ils
ont du travail tous les deux ça se passe
bien ils font beaucoup de choses entre
eux il non il y a pas de souci à chaque
fois que je les rencontre ben ils ont
l'air heureux ils ont l'air amoureux
[Musique]
c'est vraiment le un jeune
couple parfait
[Musique]
quoi alors Alexia nous a présenté
Jonathan un après-midi à la maison
on savait qu'il partait au ski un
weekend et donc elle nous l'a présenté
peut-être 8 jours après je crois mais
familièrement comme ça tiens c'est un
copain qui vient avec les autres bon et
on s'est tout de suite rendu compte que
dans les jours qui suivaient ben le
copain il était là il était encore là et
puis le 3ème jour aussi puis on s'est
dit tiens il y a peut-être quelque chose
et puis effectivement dans les semaines
qui ont suivi elle nous l'a présenté en
tant que son son petit
copain lui était plus vieux qu'elle
physiquement pas très grand alors que ma
sœur est grande et puis y a ouais il y a
comme un petit décalage entre les deux
et au début on nous dit pas de toute
façon que ça va durer toujours c'est un
petit copain au
départ
on veut pas qu'il a de chagrin d'amour
mais en tant que papa je me suis dit oh
il a l'air sympa le
PE moi je disais le parce que bon c'est
vrai que Jonathan il est il est pas bien
grand et je me rappelle une réflexion
d'Isabelle qui m'avait dit ils vont pas
ensemble il est trop petit mais c'est
c'est tout quoi
c'est je me suis dit j'espère juste que
c'est une petite passade une petite
amourette de jeune de 15 16 ans mon fort
intérieur c'est ce que
j'espérais pour moi j'imaginais pas un
garçon comme ça pour pour
Alexia je pense que quand il a débarqué
à la maison il a
trouvé une image de famille qui lui
correspondait qui lui allait bien
quelque chose de stable de permanent il
a trouvé un schéma dans lequel il a aimé
s'insérer il a aimé vivre il a aimé
àendre la place du fils de la
famille c'est comme si à la limite il
aimait plus mes parents que ma sœur au
bout d'un
[Musique]
moment
à partir du moment où la nuit tombe ça
devient
angoissant et là il y a des tas de
scénarios qui défilent dans nos têtes il
y a pas un seul scénario il y en a il y
en a
destas mais je pense que celui qui
prédomine c'est celui
du du déséquilibré qui passe et qui
l'EMB barque dans une camionnette et qu'
emmène et et qu' a qui lui fait du mal
et qui la relâche dans un coin perdu
abandonné où elle nous attend
[Musique]
quoi il fait
nuit il fait
froid c'est très perturbant pour moi je
me dis mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait là on
devrait être en train de la chercher je
sais que dans la nuit c'est pas possible
mais je me dis elle est peut-être dans
un endroit elle a froid elle a besoin de
nous et on est là on est là tous dans
cette maison
et on ne cherche pas
[Musique]
Alexia
je demande une nouvelle audition du mari
en fin de
journée alors c'est une audition qui est
très longue avec la prise des photos
c'est vraiment un témoignage qui va être
important il va y avoir deux nouveautés
la première c'est que on va découvrir
des marqu des petites marques dans ma
Braison sur les
avant-bras donc là c'est quelque chose
qui qui qui
interroge et puis spontanément Jonathan
naval nous fait part d'épisodes de
violence parfois un climat de violence
dont il est victime nous dit-il euh donc
effectivement il nous fait part de
euh une espèce de pression même de de
violence physique qu'il reçoit et c'est
comme ça qu' justifie les marques qu'il
a sur ses
[Musique]
avant-bras je me souviens d'un deuxième
élément dont il nous parle spontanément
c'est des problèmes de sexualité qu' a
avec sa compagne euh qui sont
générateurs euh chez elle nous dit-il
d'une forme d'une très forte
[Musique]
frustration il y a à partir du décès
d'Alexia ce scénario qu'il était battu
qu'il était très malheureux parce qu'on
lui reprochait ses problèmes de de de
sexualité
[Musique]
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
construction une construction je
rappelle qu'il est informaticien c'est
quelqu'un qui une intelligence qui qui
est très organisé et il y a une
organisation sur tout ce qui va
suivre
[Musique]
Jonathan on l'attendait depuis un moment
puisquil était en audition pendant près
de 3 He près des enquêteurs et quand il
arrive à la maison il arrive par la
porte du côté du salon et je me retrouve
presque en face de lui à quelques mètres
il arrive sous une couverture avec sa
mère qui qui le
porte
et ben il est venu s'asseoir sur le
canapés on l'a entourit on lui a dit
est-ce que ça va et tout et puis là il a
commencé à dire des choses sur Alexia il
a commencé à dire oui Alexia elle pique
des crises je suis obligée de la calmer
puis moi je me suis pétrifiée parce je
me suis demandé pourquoi il me racontait
ça c'est parce que je voulais entendre
je voulais je pensais plus qu'il allait
s'inquiéter de où elle était plutôt que
de me dire des choses comme ça j'ai j'ai
pas compris à ce
moment-là et puis et puis sa mère qui à
lui qui qui dit mais vas-y dis ce
qu'Alexia te faisait
subir qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
phrase devant les parents d'Alexia qui
puis nous là pour le coup il a ils ont
lui et sa mère stupéfait de tout le
monde puisque jamais personne n'a été
témoin de quelconque violence entre
Alexia et Jonathan dans un sens ni dans
l'autre a priori et je me dis mais c'est
quoi cette histoire de morsure c'est
quoi cette histoire d'Alexia qui serait
violente avec
lui montreleur là montreleur ce que tu
as là là elle a dû te mordre
ou et là je comprends pas je comprends
pas je comprends pas ce qu'elle dit je
comprends pas alex est dehors dans la
nuit et là on me montre une morsure
qu'il a sur le
bras et
là il m'a emmené dans la chambre avec ma
belle-sœur il nous ouvre un tiroir avec
des médicaments en nous disant regardez
tout ce qu'elle
s'ingurgite et là non plus je comprenais
pas
et mon épouse qui infirmière quand elle
voit le paquet de médicament elle lui
dit maisend mais c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible qu'elle
prenne tout
ça donne pas un traitement de cheval
comme ça cherche quelqu'un qui cherche à
avoir un bébé quoi donc c'est
surréaliste les médicaments Alex a
disparu et on nous fait on nous montre
quoi là j'ai pas
compris je cherche juste Alexia moi et
Alexia elle me manque déjà elle me
manque je sais
que j'ai tout j'ai l'espoir qu'on la
retrouve mais moi je suis omnubilée par
la nuit et le
[Musique]
froid et moi tout ce qui m'importe c'est
d'être le lendemain matin pour pouvoir
continuer les recherches alors ce
qu'elle dit là à l'instant présent
ça me passe au-dessus de la tête pour
l'instant les médicaments aussi ça me
passe au-dessus de la tête sur
l'instant quand on sait qu'elle a reçu
15 coups de PO quand on sait qu'elle a
été étranglée 4 minutes quand on sait
qu'elle était brûlée tirée dans des
escaliers dans les
bois toutes les blessures qu'elle a dans
le dos
[Musique]
faut savoir qu'elle a eu les ongles
retournés
hein faut le savoir ça les ongles
retournés alors oui elle a dû essayer de
se défendre mais je pense que c'est un
peu
[Musique]
normal
ouverture d'une information judiciaire
pour enlèvement et séquestration dans
l'affaire de la disparition d'Alexia
Daval cette jeune femme partie faire un
jogging samedi matin à Gray en Hute zone
le procureur de la République de vezou
se déclare de plus en plus inquiet
toutes les autres pistes comme la fugue
par exemple se referment une à une un
appel à témoins a été
lancé bah moi la nuit de samedi à
dimanche je dors pas beaucoup mon épouse
B ce jour-là donc elle se lève à 5h30 il
fait encore nuit je me lève quand même
en même temps qu'elle et je lui dis bon
écoute j'ai j'attends que le jour qu'il
fasse bien jour et je prends la voiture
et puis je vais chercher sur le le
chemin de halage puis dans les champs
sur la plaine de gréaville
quoi je pars je suis tout seul à 7h du
matin dans les champs je suis surpris
déjà d'être tout seul à ce moment-là
dans les champs à à rechercher j'ai dit
Maisie mais qu'est-ce que font les
gendarmes puis au loin j'aperçois Isabel
et Jean-Pierre qui qui recherchaent
aussi quoi et bon ils avaient rien dormi
de la nuit non plus hein n'importe
comment puis il y a Jean-Pierre qui me
dit
il y a les gendarmes qui arrivent dans
dans un quart d'heure une demi-heure qui
arrive avec les plongeurs le long de la
SAE depuis ce matin des longeur de la
gendarmerie sonde le fleuve et les
berges de la saonene tout près du
sentier où Alexia d'aval avait
l'habitude de faire son
jogging les plongeurs commencent à
sonder la saune et je me dis en moi mais
pourvu qu'il retrouve pas le corps
devant Jean-Pierre et
Isabelle pourvu qu'il retrouve pas le
corps l'angoisse grandit d'heure en
heure chez ses parents qui veulent
garder l'esoir j'attends juste qu'il la
retrouve en
envie on a besoin d'elle si quelqu'un a
des nouvelles qui nous fasse savoir au
plus vite qu'il alertent la gendarmerie
parce que on voudrait que ça aille vite
on trouve le temps très très
long alors très vite les enquêteurs se
mettent en place se mettent au travail
mais nous on a pas la communication de
l'avancement de leur enquête et moi je
ne pouvais pas
rester actif inerte comme l'était
Jonathan donc je vais entreprendre
moi-même une avancée d'enquête tout
comme le fait tiba aussi de son côté et
c'est dans cette démarche voilà que je
vais me procurer un petit carnet que je
vais remplir de tout ce qui me passe par
la tête de tout ce qui peut arriver
comme indice ou pas et l'idée de de ça
c'est de de ne rien
oublier on peut dire c'est mon carnet
d'enquête
l'une des premières pages de de mon
carnet là je note par exemple voilà à
12h05 au moment où on est à la
gendarmerie avec Jonathan où fait l' la
première audition de Jonathan
ensemble je préviens ma mère qui je lui
demande de prévenir Thérèse donc elle me
dit thérè est mise au courant et elle se
met aussitôt au
travail th est une amie de ma mère qui
est astrologue qui s'est montré par le
passé particulièrement pertinente sur
des événements de la vie de notre vie
courante voilà B je suis plutôt
cartésien donc écouter la parole d'un
voyant c'est peut-être un petit peu
rigolo mais même si j'y crois pas le but
c'est pas de savoir si j'y crois ou pas
c'est vraiment d'essayer de trouver des
éléments qui peuvent nous guider vers
Alexia pour le moment les enquêteur ne
néglige aucune piste et lance un appel à
témoin Alexia Daval mesure 1,70 à les
cheveux mil et portait hier une tenue de
sport toute personne susceptible de
fournir des informations est prié
d'appeler le
17 thérè a vu soit une altercation dans
le couple soit une agression
elle dit de chercher à l'or d'un bois
elle voit un bois tout fu de
feuillage plus tard dans la soirée j'ai
eu thér au téléphone
elle me dit qu'elle voyait Alexia
allongé endormie j'ai bien compris
qu'elle n'osait pas dire
morte tout cela c'est ensuite avéré
parfaitement
[Musique]
exacte cet après-midi des amis des
voisins des anonymes plus de 200
personnes ont participer à une
battue il y avait un monde de fou tous
les gens avait envie de nous aider et
franchement ça m'a fait vraiment du bien
de voir tous ces gens je me suis dit on
on va y arrivver on va y
arriver si on la trouve pas c'est
qu'elle est encore envie quelque part
j'espère qu'on va pas je la trouver
vivante c'est tout ce qui
m'importe on était tous les uns à côté
des autres et on avance petit pas par
petit
pas pour voir dans les bosquets ou si on
retrouvait quelque
chose au bout d'un moment l'après-midi
se déroule et je reçois un coup de
téléphone et j'ai ma petite vendeuse du
bar qui me dit il y a un monsieur qui
veut vous parler il a une information
importante à vous à vous
donner c'est un voyant et il me dit je
vois Alexia à moulin dans un bois et on
était à côté du
bois il me dit je la vois au milieu du
bois entre deux arbres et et là je passe
le téléphone à Jean-Pierre il y avait
mes neveux qui étaient là et j'envoie
mes neveux
là-bas nous partons de suite avec Carlos
jérô et liydia on visite quelques champs
dans les environs puis on arrive à
l'entrée du bois vers la vierge mais on
est arrêté par deux militaires qui
bloquent l'entrée nous essayons d'entrer
dans le bois un peu plus loin mais cette
fois une camionnette de gendarme nous
stoppe et tout d'un coup on entend un
gendarme qui dit on arrête tout on
arrête tout là alors que il faisit
soleil donc on pouvait encore chercher
facilement une bonne demi-heure dans le
bois entre Velet et puis
[Musique]
émoulin
je suis informé immédiatement par le
command groupement me signalant doncun
corps vient d'être retrouvé en partie
calcinée allongé entre deux Tron
[Musique]
d'arbrees
on aperçoit donc le corps d'une personne
partiellement
calcité allongé sur le dos visage
tuméfié recouvert d'un drap
blanc et surtout ce qui ce qui marque
lorsqu'on voit l'état du corps c'est que
les lunettes ne sont pas brisées elles
ne sont pas déformé ça donne
l'impression qu'on a remis les lunettes
en place
moi je suis omnibulé par la découverte
du corps parce que je sais que ce corps
et donc la scène de crime permettra de
la découverte de nombreux indices donc
je me rends je me rends sur les
lieux on trouve un visage tuéfié tu
méfié et on voit
effectivement une strangulation qui est
déjà très très
abîmé on a énormément d'éléments on a la
tenue jogueuse c'estes lunettes la
crémation il y a une dimension
symbolique à la crémation d'un corps et
bien sûr qui confirme que c'est un
proche qui fait
[Musique]
ça la difficulté que j'ai elle est
d'ordre
aussi j'allais dire psychologique
c'est imaginez annoncer cela aux parents
c'est quelque chose de de très difficile
pour lesquels j'ai encore j'ai encore
des des des
souvenirs alors c'était tellement
difficile que j'ai laissé une une porte
ouvertees en disant qu'on a retrouvé un
corps mais tant que l'autopsie était pas
faite le jeudi on ne pouvait pas être
sûr à 100 % qu' siss d'Alexia mais je
crois que malgré mes précautions
ratoires les parents savaient avaient
senti
on est dans un bureau avec
Jonathan à la gendarmerie de
gré on a le procureur en face de nous
euh je je suis assis à droite j'ai
Jean-Pierre et Jonathan à côté de
Jean-Pierre mon monde
s'effondrait ma vie s'écroulait c'était
pas possible
c'est pas entendable d'avoir une vie qui
qui s'écroule en en 24 he c'est pas
possible c'est
pas Jonathan naval a un comportement don
je me souviens encore très bien
aujourd'hui ce comportement un petit peu
larmmoyant espèce de comportement
fuyant qui m'a
qui m'a gêné
et et j'ai le souvenir dans
l'espace ce petit local où je leur
annonce ça un bureau de gendarme que
j'avais
réquisitionné les les deux parents sont
à ma gauche
sétraigne et puis il y a il y a
Jonathan c'est un moment difficile parce
que devant moi j'ai quelqu'un qui
possiblement est un
suspect mais je fais le choix que je ne
regrette pas à ce moment précis de pas
le placer en garde à vue parce que nous
n'avons pas assez
d'éléments alors il va rentrer dans une
stratégie de manipulation de
dissimulation qu'il avait en fait
organisé et donc effectivement ce qui
est extrêmement troublant et rare c'est
d'être même capable de rester dans la
famille dans la place qu'il
a finalement remplaçant la fille qui a
disparu
je vois le grand mensonge comme les
enquêteurs et plus effectivement
l'enquête va durer plus ce grand
mensonge va
durer